MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
I'm Martin Omander, a Developer
Advocate on the Serverless
team.
CRAIG LABENZ: And I'm Craig
Labenz, a Developer Relations
Engineer on the Cloud SQL team.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
Cloud SQL, you say?
That's perfect
because I'm looking
to deploy my app on Cloud
Run, but it's back end
uses a relational database.
And I'm not sure how
to combine the two.
CRAIG LABENZ: Ah, yes.
Many developers are using
serverless architectures
with relational databases.
Why don't you show me
what you're building,
and we can take it from there?
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, Craig,
I've decided to settle
one of the greatest programming
head scratchers of all time.
CRAIG LABENZ: Ah,
GIF versus "jif?"
MARTIN OMANDER:
No, not that one.
CRAIG LABENZ: What
color is the dress?
MARTIN OMANDER: No, Craig.
I said programming.
I created a web app to poll
whether developers prefer
tabs or spaces in their code.
CRAIG LABENZ: Oh, I love that
idea, because the answer will
obviously be [BLEEP].
Now, your app is
definitely going
to get millions of daily
active users from day one,
so you'll need to be thoughtful
with its infrastructure.
Can you show me what you have?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep, my
app's code is ready to go.
There's a simple front
end that displays the most
recent votes plus the totals.
Also, there's a form at the
bottom that collects new votes.
CRAIG LABENZ: OK, that sounds
like a pretty standard web app.
Now, you mentioned using
SQL for its back end.
What went into that decision?
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, I plan
to have several Cloud Run
services that periodically
run analysis on my data.
And SQL is really
good at aggregations
like sums and averages.
CRAIG LABENZ: Hmm,
yeah, that makes sense.
It sounds like Cloud
SQL is actually
the right choice for your app.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
that's good to hear.
But my fear using SQL with
a serverless architecture
is that Postgres
and MySQL databases,
that they don't scale
up automatically
like Cloud Functions
or Cloud Run.
CRAIG LABENZ: Oh,
we've all been there.
Now, luckily,
traditional SQL databases
have a lot of tricks
you can use to squeeze
every last drop of performance
out of your hardware.
What do you say we
deploy your app,
and then we'll run
some load tests?
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
Let's get this baby shipped.
All right, so I'm ready to
create my database instance
here in Cloud SQL.
I click Create Instance.
And ah, the first thing, it
asks me for database engine.
Do you have any recommendation?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well, all three
provide a modern SQL database,
but the community seems to
be agreeing on Postgres-style
SQL for new products.
So looking ahead,
choosing Postgres
will set you up nicely for
upgrades in the future.
But of course, every
decision that we make here
will be the same for
MySQL or SQL Server.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So I'll call my
instance poll-database.
There we go.
And I'll enter a super
secret password here.
Let's see, secretpassword.
All right.
Now, regarding location,
I'm in California,
so I'm physically closest
to, let's see, ah, US West.
But to make sure I have the
same experience as users
far from California,
I think I'll deploy
my app to maybe Europe North.
CRAIG LABENZ: Oh,
that's so clever.
By not deploying your app
to the nearest region,
you'll be able to see if
users far from your servers
have degraded experiences.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, and, of course,
if I know that all my
users are in one place,
I would deploy my
app to that region.
But I have a question, Craig.
I put this in Finland now.
But can I then relocate my
Cloud SQL instance later on?
CRAIG LABENZ: Oh,
yes, of course.
Moving your database
location is as
easy as creating a read
replica in your new region,
waiting for it to catch
up to your main database,
and then promoting it.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, cool.
Next one is database version.
I'll pick the latest available.
Configuration options,
it says there.
Oh, there is a lot here.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah, there is.
Luckily, they're not too bad.
The first item,
Connectivity, offers a lot
of different ways
of establishing
a secure connection
to your database.
The Private IP option
allows you to connect
to a virtual private cloud.
But I don't recommend
that for newer apps.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, yeah,
I want to start simple
but in a way that
doesn't prevent me
from growing in the future.
CRAIG LABENZ: For sure.
And you can always add a virtual
private cloud down the line
should you desire.
So this means the default
connectivity options should
be exactly what you
want, because Cloud Run
is designed to connect to
Cloud SQL right out of the box.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
I love it when things
work right out of the box.
OK, so closing connectivity.
I'm opening machine
type and storage.
What should I pick here?
CRAIG LABENZ: Now,
here, I usually
start with the
smallest machine that
qualifies for
Google service level
agreement, which is one virtual
CPU and 3.75 gigabytes of RAM.
Now estimating hardware
needs ahead of time
is extremely
difficult for any app,
especially one not
yet launched, which
is why we're going to
run some load tests.
MARTIN OMANDER: [CHUCKLES] Cool.
So I pick one virtual CPU,
3.75 gigabytes of RAM here.
But what if I find out that I
chose the wrong size later on?
What then?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well, if
your app can tolerate
a few minutes of downtime,
more database power
is never further away than
turning off your instance,
resizing it, and
turning it back on.
Of course, if your app
cannot tolerate a few minutes
of downtime, then the
standard workflow is the same
as changing regions.
You create a larger
read replica,
wait until it catches
up to production,
and then promote it.
Now, next, as for storage
type and encryption,
I strongly recommend
solid state drives
and Google-managed encryption.
Those are easy wins, and
they reduce your headaches.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK.
Let's see.
So it looks like
next is Backups.
Ah, great, looks like
backups are on by default.
And closing Backups.
Then we have Flags, Maintenance,
Query Insights, Labels.
That sounds like
extra credit, so I
think we might be good to go.
I'm clicking Create.
CRAIG LABENZ: You've taken your
first step into a larger world.
But say, we've got a few minutes
while this database instance
gets created.
Top off coffee?
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
well, tea for me.
But yeah, that sounds great.
All right, I refilled my tea,
and my database is created.
Before we go any further,
I'll use Cloud Shell
to create all of my tables.
So if I scroll down
here, I can click
Connect using Cloud Shell.
All right, so I'm
in, and I'm going
to paste in the statements
to create the tables.
There it is.
All right.
So now, my next
question is, what values
should I use in my code
to connect to my Cloud SQL
instance?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well, usually,
you would use your database's IP
address.
But Cloud Run
creates a Unix socket
in your running container
for each connected Cloud SQL
instance.
This means all that your
application code has to do
is to that socket file.
I sent you a working
code sample earlier.
Did you get it?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Socket.txt-- yeah, right.
This is the one you
sent to me, right?
CRAIG LABENZ: Yes.
So with that, you can copy
that and go back into main.py.
And you can remove the
host and port arguments,
and, instead, supply
that copied code
as the path to your
Unix socket file.
And like all of our other
database connection values,
it's best to read that path
from an environment variable.
Now, in Cloud Run the path is
always /cloudsql/ your database
connection name, which you can
find on your Cloud SQL instance
screen.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So let's see.
I have an environment file here.
I took out host and port.
So, and in my
database-- ah, right.
There's the connection name.
Cool.
I'll just copy that.
So that's the connection.
CRAIG LABENZ: Yeah,
so you can put
all the values in this file.
And for the database user, we
use the default Postgres user
of postgres.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Postgres, got it.
CRAIG LABENZ: And
I'm sure you remember
your best-in-class password.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
yes, uncrackable.
CRAIG LABENZ: And we also use
the default Postgres database,
very nice.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, postgres.
There we are.
All right, so I placed
a database username,
and password, database
name, and connection name.
CRAIG LABENZ: Now, it looks like
we're ready to deploy your app.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I
have a script prepared
that handles the entire
deployment process.
CRAIG LABENZ: Well,
that sounds amazing.
Can I see it?
MARTIN OMANDER: I'll just
start it really quick here.
So what this does
is, up here, it
sets three environment
variables that
would be used further down.
And then it's two steps.
So the first one is
gcloud builds submit,
which just packages everything
up in this directory
and sends it to Cloud
Build, a Google build server
that builds the container.
That's what's
going on right now.
And then down here
is gcloud run deploy,
which takes that container and
deploys it as a new Cloud Run
service.
Also, it includes here
add instances flag
that sends along
the connection name
so that Cloud Run knows
which database to connect to.
CRAIG LABENZ: Wow.
And to think, now, you
can deploy your entire app
with just a few key presses.
This is really
going to lend itself
to a nice CI/CD pipeline.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, it looks
like the deploy was a success.
Let's see if it loads.
I'll go to this.
You're all here.
It looks like I've connected
Cloud Run, which is serverless,
with a traditional SQL database
running on dedicated hardware.
I can scale it up by adding
CPU memory or read replicas.
But will I need to do that?
How much traffic can my
system handle, Craig?
CRAIG LABENZ: Well all
apps are different.
And the only way to know
is to run a load test.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds great.
Stay tuned for in the next
video, where we do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]